vous aviez entendu parler de despotes
éclairés
oui bien sûr alors décrivez moi jamais
je n'ai pas vu mais pas vu quoi et bah
despote éclairé enfin je sais que c'est
pour éclairer certaines vues traîneau et
à quoi ça sert
pour attirer le regard voyez ce que
c'est le régime castriste
oui c'est au couple est parti à une
personne qu'on plus qu'ils puissent
chanter puis j'ai vu une personne pas
une personne neutre humain quoi en bout
femmes ont mis fin au non on prend forme
pourquoi les femmes
est ce que c'est que les potentats les
potentats serait pas
d
potes qui sont qui sont tous rassemblés
pendant une fête tout ça qui sont soit
des gens qui s'amusent quoi qui font la
fête
moi je pense et pourquoi leurs tentes
parce que y'a plein de potes qui sont
rassemblés en main tu as quoi simplement
vous avez déjà entendu parler de
plébiscite non qu'est ce que c'est votre
avis bah plébiscite c'est une plus haut
des ouvertures peut-être vous plaît deux
ouvertures d'une plaie à deux ouvertures
vous plaît et bi et bi ça veut dire deux
le couvre-feu vous voyez ce que c'est
oui je crois
j'en ai un chez moi alors qu'est ce que
c'est ben c'est quelque chose que l'on
met sur la cuisinière électrique qui
sait ça sert à protéger a décoré aussi
c'est à protéger quoi le couvre feu les
plaques chauffantes dans les émirats du
golfe les troupes les les trous on lance
la balle dedans qui s'appellerait les
émirats du golfe plénipotentiaire qu'est
ce que ça veut dire par exemple un
ministre plénipotentiaire un ministre
qui mérite d'être défendue alors
qu'appelle-t-on l'état d'urgence mais de
faire les petites tailles de ranger
ensuite les petites sommes mais de
chaussures de jouer afin de choses qui
gênent
pourquoi fait-on les petits tas mais dix
ans pour pour un j'ai appris c'est
pourquoi d'urgence alors parce qu'un
ticket quelqu'un improvise on ne peut
pas se permettre deux minutes d'orange
et du fou alors dans ces cas là on fait
un plein plan d'urgence donc le
référendum a lancé ses bonhommes qui
fait marcher les hommes qui les fait
marcher comme un grand
un marché droit des filets et tout dans
quels cas d'un cadre du 14 juillet et 15
août
comment il fait qu'on me dit il fait
alors une 2e à droite à gauche tam et
voudront à la tête en l'air
sortez le ventre entre deux derrière un
peu tout quoi c'est un bon référendum
qu'appelle-t-on les grosses légumes dans
un gouvernement
les grosses légumes dans un gouvernement
cesson
les légumes qu'ils peuvent faire tomber
les gouvernements exemple quel genre de
légumes alors bas les betteraves pour
les betteraves bahamas que les
betteraves ça produit du sucre et si le
sucre marche plus gouvernement il se
casse la gueule
un triumvirat qu'est-ce que ses mains un
triumvirat ça se passe dans les
entreprises
ça c'est ce que c'est ça vient du grec
sûrement comme j'ai fait du grec
ça doit venir trium ça vient de trier et
vire à vire et est alors veut dire trier
les gens pour les virées dans quelles
circonstances main par exemple quand il
faut licencier dans une entreprise
[Musique]